[Music]
joey is joining us in the studio here if
we could switch over he's got some sick
outfit on well uh if you'll notice he's
standing next to a whiteboard and most
of you most of you will probably see
that those are Hideo Kojima
kind of Metal Gear Solid all Metal Gear
it's all Metal Gear characters
organizations and activities Joey edit
naked cartwheels which I bribed in fans
out there um yeah and I know this is
confusing and we're still kind of
confused I'm kidding we are going to so
last week tribeca Games Festival in New
York City took place and Hideo Kojima
was there to talk about kind of deaf
stranding and movie influences and just
inspiration in general and they asked if
he were to make a movie what it would be
and people asked us all the time because
of your solid Okajima x' games in
general are always super his body is 70%
movie cinematic yeah ah between escape
from New York
Titanic um die hard they're all kind of
big influences but did you see though
during that SEMA interview I don't know
if you read it escape from New York
Snake Plissken is not the influence that
went into Metal Gear Solid it was
actually Robert De Niro from deer hunter
for me it was yeah interesting my whole
life is alive it's [ __ ]
regardless some point he answered if I
were to start making a movie I might not
finish it because he loves movies so
much but he also said he would be up for
a big-budget blockbuster which I think
we would all expect or a smaller feature
with a few characters in a single room a
la diehard um
single building single room you get me
so Pete Brown brought the idea to us I
mean only what if what if a Okajima did
direct not just a movie in the future
but some of our favorite movies for the
past yeah and I'm gonna let Pete kind of
describe the rules of this more
open-ended segment and Joey is going to
help us out and we're going to do some
some weird stuff all right so because
we're basing this on pre-existing movies
we can't just start from scratch right
so what I've done is I've created sort
of a Madlib scenario where we can use
the terms that Joey has up there plus
you know verbs
adjectives that we just think up to
rewrite the synopsis that was originally
found on the back of the movie box the
VHS stop the VHS or the DVD in some
sherry shank and the rules are each new
suggestion comes from the next host at
the podium so we're going to go down the
line one by one so we're not just
shouting over each other key movie
characters have to be replaced with key
Metal Gear characters that's because we
in middle make sense in a second it does
host may veto one suggestion per slot
barring it's for the bet the good of the
film and Hideo Kojima the synopsis must
retain the spirit of the original film
and also must acquire the spirit of
Hideo Kojima lastly one more rule
everyone please take this very seriously
also last role you didn't add it have
fun have fun take it seriously
I believe I'm gonna kick this off right
and so we are going to roll a trailer
after we fill this in and mike is going
to read the synopsis over it and rob is
sort of cut trailers for these okay cool
or less so alright repeat I need a
character um fat man okay
alright Rob I need an organization wait
who wants like just add fat man across
I'm in across it outside rollerblading
demolitions expert organization uh
Foxhound okay
Kelly I need an adjective any adjectives
get weird with it
no don't get me um explosive nice oh
that's really good
verb Pete um smell okay Robin yeah
location Bermuda Callie another
adjective big
Pete I need an activity oh yeah here um
go with cloning hey hell yeah you guys
have taken all the good ones
Rob another activity separate one I
already started Reno's uh I'm not gonna
take flurry no I'm gonna do it someone
else and do that uh developing MOOCs you
know the other good one I have I said
what movie this is yet should I wait
okay yeah you should wait all right uh
Callie adjectives again um naked
nice know that that's not net no it is
this is uh to say okay another character
Pete another character I'm gonna go with
Meryl nice Meryl this is alright another
character Rob Vulcan Raven ha ha ha all
right uh did I get a location yet no I
did not
Callie I need location wait I thought
I'd rob you rob baby boomer is it the
same location I can't look it is if it
says location one you're totally right
I'm sorry
um ok Callie I need a plural noun bombs
okay
Oh story in life I need a relationship
Pete oh boy uh kissing cousins okay
[Music]
horrible batshit insane uh uh Rob
another or nothing never mind lon
let me fill out this I got organization
one again okay Rob adjective uh smelly
Callie one more adjective and then this
is the last one get nuts with it um
exotic okay so should I tell the movie
yet or we just gonna roll the trailer
and all over the trailer that's right
and you go ahead and read it you can go
any time these are about a minute thirty
long okay less than that so consider the
clock down there if you need to all
right John Luke hit me with it I don't
know which movie it is oh um it's it's
the one that starts with s what about
the stars in s there's a lot of boys in
it I can do that okay thank you sorry my
bad are you gonna unmute the TV no we're
good
yeah alright here we go it's the early
1960s and fat man has just moved into
town with his Fox hound kids call an
explosive he can't even throw a baseball
but that changes when the leader of
Foxhound invites him to smell on the
nearby Bermuda field at the beginning of
a big summer of cloning while developing
nukes first kisses and naked
confrontation with the dreaded Meryl and
his owner Vulcan Raven who lived behind
Bermuda soon nine bombs have become best
kissing cousins fat man is a part of Fox
sound and their leader has become a
local legend in this smelly and exotic
comedy
and that's the synopsis right there
let's keep rolling this oh yeah we
probably should have slowed us down let
me skip ahead now you're good
Breanna is the kissing cousin who didn't
come yeah wow that was an actual edit
the sandlot a Okajima film there we go
hello there we go
all right as that was what it would be
like if Jo Kojima directed sandlot one
of my favorite movies of all time all
right
Peet's your turn this one's got a lot of
adjectives Mike give me an adjective
phrase bombastic okay Rob I need an
adjective sweaty all right I need
another education Kelley short short
uh actually I'm gonna view to that one
okay
mmm hairy type ie one more adjectives
I'm not joking um superfluous okay I
need a plural noun uh go-carts sorry
everyone
uh uh I need an adjective
Oh for me um
terrible terrible uh I'm gonna pass on
that one sorry I just want this to be
perfect like I said Dana Kojima would
would do it okay um effervescent okay
sure uh right I need a noun uh
grandmother right I need a number
Oh God
ten okay I need an adjective go to
Everett um
romantic you're gonna feet okay okay no
no no no no it's good it's good
I need another adjective please mmm
leathery Wow
actually yeah that works damn looking at
Richard's boots
I always body part uh arm okay all right
character so does a Miller character
it's the first time if you like me use
as much as it should be revolver ocelot
cool all right I need a noun
Michael feces oh sorry I shouldn't uh
down Robert
I'd desk sure you look good adjectives I
know we've got a couple more to go um
blind all right I need a plural noun and
then we're good mmm lizards all right
roll that beautiful footage of the start
to the G starts the G Mike
[Music]
from the imagination of Hideo Kojima The
Goonies plunges a band of bombastic
heroes into a sweaty surprise around
every corner quest beyond their wildest
dreams
following a hairy treasure map into a
spectacular underground realm of
twisting passages superfluous booby
go-karts and a long effervescent pirate
ship full of golden grandmothers begin
the kids race to stay ten steps ahead of
a family of bumbling romantic guys and a
leathery monster with an arm only a
revolver ocelot could love I love it
alright I'm gonna give it a second I
give it a second okay a feces adventure
classic from start to buccaneering
finish The Goonies is a cinematic desk
trove of blind action dazzling lizards
and shivery Timbers thrills
[Laughter]
alright that was not good I was just a
weird above the weird one that was weird
alright I think we could probably go the
next right yeah we're sorry
alright moving are not now we're going
to Cali but I'll just joining we are
getting to zelda breath of the wild DLC
and Darksiders three stuff this is just
if Hideo Kojima made our favorite movies
because of that quote from the Tribeca
games festivals for idiots Peter I need
a location um alright I'm going to say
South Africa that's a little I
occasionally uh plumber okay
a character uh big boss okay um a
different location here um
Oakland okay uh adjectives uh did we use
effervescent why is that in my head we
did okay that's why oh uh flamboyant
okay I know how to spell that
okay I remember one movie yes sir oh
yeah I do one event the apocalypse well
you better be able to read this um chats
been spinning these out um dance
if you to that okay um
strangle yeah and hunt you and uh
organization PETA Oh from there mmm
[ __ ] I like peanut butter alright
Diamond Dogs it's kind of like PETA uh
noun submarine okay does it work yes
okay this is the same diamond dogs okay
character to any a second character I'm
going to say Coleman adjectives plural I
mean it's for you plural noun it just
adjectives okay um
foamy no no thank you
oceanic that works with the submarine oh
here we go now
um swordfish
okay I think we've lost sight of what
the real goal is here um definitely
crying um soldier no Metal Gear Rex
yeah Metal Gear Rex Thank You suggestion
Oh to get us back to Cody yeah good
point yeah you're right
um noun um Metal Gear RAY no thank you
denote um I don't know nanobot okay I
like metal machine in a machine a
machine oh this is character one big
boss uh no katana
slippery oh okay thank you and adjective
[Music]
gaseous okay um John Luke rolled d movie
yeah Bruce Willis stars as South Africa
plumber big boss newly arrived in okay
to spend the Christmas holiday with his
flamboyant wife
but uh but as Big Boss waits for his
wife's office a pilot strangle Diamond
Dogs seize control of the submarine
while the Diamond Dogs leader Coldman
and his oceanic henchmen Roundup
swordfish yeah Big Boss slips away
unnoticed armed with only a Metal Gear
Rex at his nanomachine Big Boss launches
his own one-man katana a slippery
thriller from beginning to end
diehard explodes with gaseous cash is
what get and a hard man to kill die die
hard you trip the narrator up with your
edit okay what yeah yeah
oh man man that's my life all right
let's do this last one kind of quick
yeah a long one and let's then we'll get
to Darksiders and Zelda and let's really
try to stick to metal gear okay like we
can do it you wanna still do it move on
mMmmm I kind of want to do it let's do
it okay we committed to it let's do it
planet Saturn adjective uh
[Music]
roundabouts another adjective bazaar are
you cranky number I'm definitely 400
Academy Award uh pass Best Original
Screenplay adjectives deadly genre
comedy plural noun
um rollerblading demolition experts are
bde for sure um um I'm prescient feet
okay just cuz you don't
yeah that's it oh yeah how about uh
Florida
sure nice timeframe um so I will say uh
week rank mmm private first class
another rank a different one for me yeah
um CEO instead of rank sure we have not
hit melech here yeah uh character one
there we go oh here we go
thank various tiers Joey character one
za me yeah
liquid snake
character to ridin look how much the few
captain's Joe Jesus
plural noun me um oh no oh no as use
sorry um bullets mm-hmm controversy
controversy uh-huh
okay let me see if I can uh no it's it's
me Shadow Moses incident oh it's okay
now right side shut shut up Moses
Institute sorry you can take next one
comes your first weirdest category of
word verb uh uh
Fulton conspire dude torture
let's go torture yeah sorry babe yeah
adjectives a proper noun
Oh's Emmy yeah um
the USS Enterprise adjective uh
[Music]
smokey no no sorry disastrous wait Oh do
a long one
noun word robe malfunction nice
adjective uh
sneaky cross it cross that plural noun
philosophers I used one of the
organization adjective aromatic is good
a room Eric green aromatic aromatic nice
one Eric really thank you for your dream
has guy giving me two so far number uh
[Music]
ninety-one adjective
horrific we're all going to lose our
jobs after this adjective that's it last
one
um good late
you don't give me one more okay um cut
did Joey help oh it's only you do
murderous murderous all right here we go
my boy thank you for singing with us
bear with me on this one if hideo kojima
directed this movie this is what it
would be spin it nothing on saturn can
rival round about spectacle and bizarre
grandeur of titanic winner of 400
Academy Awards including Best Original
Screenplay this deadly comedy story
sailed into the hearts of rollerblading
demo experts around the globe ultimately
emerging as the most florid motion
picture of the week international
international private first class
private first class Leonardo DiCaprio
and Oscar CEO Kate Winslet lineup excuse
me wind-up sorry light up the screen as
liquid snake and right the young bullets
separated by Shadow Moses incident right
yeah the Shadow Moses incident yet does
destined to torture each other on mate
hahahaha named voyage of the flirty RMS
USS Enterprise but when the but when did
sorry uh but when the disasters sorry
Jesus but when the doom disasters liner
what [ __ ]
but when the doom disasters liner
collides with a wardrobe malfunction and
the sneaky North Atlantic they're their
philosophers love affair becomes an
aromatic race to a first survival from
acclaimed filmmaker and ninety-one Oscar
winner a Okajima comes a tale of
horrific love in the face of disaster
that triumph
as a murderous cinematic masterpiece all
right would we got through it
alright for those joining those were
some of our favorite movies as directed
by Hideo Kojima had been also not but
also I just kind of Madeleine that some
classic 90s movies uh alright let's talk
about video games so let me come back
down to earth for a second Joe he's done
no no he's unboxing that [ __ ] right now
Joey yankee on those are live production
oh man who's naked cartwheels remains
[Music]